like do you ever get inspiration from
you know works outside you know just
from like normal manga that you like
find elements that you can incorporate
into like your work yeah i mean like if
you look at a
sex scene it's basically an action scene
so if you read like battle manga you can
there's a lot of like angles and like
movements i agree okay i can never tell
what the [ __ ] is going on
and both i'm like
yeah so
when okay
can you expand like like whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa i get it i get
it yeah
you're you're basically just um
depicting movement right um
so like
how do you get that across like on a
still image right oh okay so you know
you know you do like in and out in and
out yeah yeah yeah that's like one way
to do it right if you read battle manga
you could like you know we could
incorporate in and out in one picture
[Laughter]
what about like the pacing and tempo
over battled like does that play into
factors i've yeah i've never i've never
thought
yeah yeah i just thought that sex scenes
were just battle scenes
you just think that because bucky said
so
maybe yeah
i'd argue the greatest fight scene in
bucky is the sex scene because the
tension of the fight feels the same as
the tension of a sex scene
that's true in a lot of ways yeah a good
a good the tension in a good fight scene
and the attention of the good sex scene
is like
yeah
it's exactly the same i guess
[Laughter]
yeah like
i guess i guess i'm so curious to to
like hear what like what does that break
down into are you talking about like
just movement or just like the tempo or
the pacing
and movement like
let's say um
you're having a sex scene right right
and you'll notice there's a large panel
yeah something happening and there's
there'll be a small panel of like some
guy flipping his wrist right and then
the next scene you'll see how he's using
that as his hand yeah in a different way
and it's the same thing in a battle
manga you know you're right
one guy's fighting but then he does a
small movement and you'll see a small
panel yeah where they show that and then
that gets incorporated into the next
scene
okay that's so interesting so
like it's like kind of creating like a
flow right of movement so do you like
when you when you're when you're drawing
this do you have like a kind of like a
rough storyboard in your mind about how
the paneling is going to be
um
you're like sketching out i sketched it
out beforehand right but you know there
are different
you know
you have different templates in your
mind yeah yeah yeah and like
you go by those templates and then once
in a while you want to change it up yeah
make it interesting right right right
right so i'm i think
the more experience you have the more
templates you have in your mind right so
it doesn't become like monotonous okay
okay
that's so it yeah because i've never
thought of it like that but now that
you've said it out loud it just it makes
so much sense
everyone everyone saw the moment where
it just like clicked and gone he's like
you know like you can see the light bulb
just like oh
god's going to be watching like
demonstrate getting bricked up
like damn that flow of movement though
so you're telling me so you're telling
me if you for animate sex scenes it's
just going to be the greatest get the
greatest greatest
the greatest fight back in the 90s you
had like top animators doing hentai yeah
yeah i know i know not so much these
days but like you know back in the day
it was like we have big names you know
yeah unfortunately we have queen bee
nowadays
[Music]
but yeah like i i do know that like
hentai back in the day had some like in
terms of like animation studio and
animators working on it it was like some
big big names
yeah yeah yeah
now it's like very much you know
the same kind of glossy look the same
kind of template there's less now we're
back to drawing like a frame and then
just moving it on camera like this yeah
yeah yeah i mean it's not all like that
but there's definitely
less
like
experimentation right but now you have
amateurs who are doing amazing like
like um animation work
just on their own yeah yeah yeah like uh
the one in the italian senate
yeah yeah the t for one of the t4 yeah
it was very impressive yeah like some of
them some of the most impressive hence i
work so i think we're going like full
circle we have a lot of talent working
in like just doing sex scenes now yeah
yeah yeah
you know hopefully it'll keep going that
way yeah because like i like so like
some of the most talented artists and
talented animators i've seen
um
in the porn world has been independent
and i'm just like damn what if i saw
like because normally you only get to
see like a minute or two of animation
which is of course as much as you're
going to be able to see from one person
right it's like man what if he had like
an actual 30 minute episode that like
actually looks like this that would be
like insane
give that man some money yeah yeah right
right give this man a studio right now
give him a production
that'll be amazing yeah anyway i i don't
have anything more to ask you me neither
man i think i've been i'm i'm full i'm
full i am i'm there was so much good
food
i am like enlightened i am fulfilled
right now oh one last question okay
is hentai art yeah
okay
i thought we knew this
now no one can argue on twitter
confirmed right here